Grace is being a difficult tournament
for EU so far but finally you got that
elusive Victory tell us about your
feelings right now
um I mean I'm just glad that I won a
game nice I found the combination I
guess so I'm just trying to take it one
game at a time and I'm happy that I won
this game tell us about this experience
playing against the best junior girls in
the nation you being one of them how do
you feel about it I mean it's really
nice I get to play like a lot of tough
competition like you just said and I
think it's just a really great
experience overall and I'm grateful for
the opportunity and you're also a
college level right at uh at this point
is that correct yeah I'm mentoring my
first year and how do you combine this
academic career as well as your chess
career I mean I've usually been able to
balance it pretty well like get my
schoolwork out of the way like start
like practice chess um usually I'm able
to get that in and yeah otherwise I mean
academics comes first obviously but I'm
usually able to follow up with enough
practice in between well uh big victory
for you Gracie I have to say
congratulations it's been a pleasure to
watch today's game guys any questions
or congratulations but
Kate please yeah I do have a question
congratulations Gracie on a really nice
game I always admire players who you
know have a tournament that's not going
their way I know it's always difficult
for me but they continue fighting and
then they actually make the win so I'm
curious how is your mindset in this
tournament like with that perseverance
that you don't just resign the game
don't just like play something to make a
draw but you still fight how do you keep
that
um I mean like of course I'm obviously
trying to go for the win in each game
and um as you can see it hasn't been
working out that well this tournament
but I just try to keep the fresh
perspective on it um try to win every
game ticket like it's a new
um opportunity and go from there yeah I
think that's that's really what it's all
about yeah yeah keeping a positive frame
of mind
thank you Gracie and good luck tomorrow
yeah good luck in the last round thank
you